hey what's up guys my name is a journal
welcome to episode 48 of game
programming so today we're going to take
a look at animating our lovely lovely
player qingchun oh so last time we
talked about this 32 aside sprites and
you know that if I open up paint.net you
can see that we've actually got a lot
more than just that little thing right
we've got all these different things now
I'm actually going to split up the
episode about animating into two
episodes because there's two different
animations that go on here
the first animation that goes on here is
which way is he facing so there's when
he's going up I guess up or forward when
he's going right when it's going down or
what else is the other one it's going
down or backwards I guess without people
appellants yeah that would be backwards
down backwards and the final one is left
now there's a kind of redundant and like
these two because we could just flip
this one we're using covered using code
and actually get that result your honor
man like we got it we could just like
scale it horizontally to like negative
one hundred percent if that's how you
roll I don't know if you guys understand
that terminology but the short answer is
we could just flip flip this right image
in code to get the left image and thus
we wouldn't actually need to paint that
but the way I said you know you might as
well it'll be easy to do it I mean the
person who sent me this and he wall he
actually um died you know I didn't
actually ask this so so he um he did it
this way um if I was drawing it I
probably wouldn't bother like he's not
hard to do you can just duplicate this
one and then flip it right and painted
man or any other image image editing
software but um you know I guess the
point is that it you don't really need
that it's kind of you know redundant but
it's alright we'll work with that so
that's going to be the first thing that
we're going to deal with the directions
so in other words when we're going down
we want to use this particular sprite
now that's great let's close our game I
really like that shade of blue by the
way it's awesome I'm going to use that
shade of blue for water when we get
around to that right now it's just the
void tail okay so hmm I can't I can't
wait to finish this player stuff and get
up and get and get into like actual
level level design that'll be so sick
anyway
the first thing I do is actually create
all the sprites so you can see that
right over here that's like five down I
believe on a thirty-two sized scale and
then we've got one across two across and
three across
so one across is right
two across is down and three horses left
okay so let's let's go back into eclipse
and over here in our sprite Java class
well then we'll get rid of this player
for now the the one that was four
corners four different things since
we're using the 32000-1 and I'll rename
this to something like just for you guys
just to help you guys understand
I'll probably just call them play it
forward all right I'll play it up that's
that's that one alright so I'll give it
a nice elaborate big name I probably
would have just called it something like
player F if I was just doing this for
myself but um just for you guys I'll
keep its nice and clear
so we'll duplicate that three times
right and it will make player back oops
backward will call play back player left
and player right okay and over here I
think the back one I'm just sold tabbing
between these back one is number two
across so number by diameter across I'm
talking of course about the X location
of the pixel from which the sprite
starts so in other words that's going to
be zero remember that's going to be one
that's going to be two and then that's
going to be three so the one that's
going backwards is is this one which is
number two across so 0 1 2 so 2 and then
left of course is 3
and whoops and one is right okay so
again we will actually be doing this
we're not going to be flipping it using
code if you guys want me to show you how
to flip a player in other words how to
just not use this sprite but just use
these three and when we come across to
having to go left we'll just flip this
one in code if you guys want me to show
you that in the next episode leave a
comment below let me know I am actually
making these daily I'm not like
buffering than my guests by building
like but by spending like a day and
making ten episodes at once I am sort of
doing this daily just because I'm pissy
with other stuff I guess don't have time
to set them up but um because of that I
can actually like listen to what you
guys say in the comments so if you do
want me to do a flip thing like if you
want me to show you guys how to flip
sprites leave a comment below and I'll
do that in the next episode otherwise
I'll just ignore that because you know
we've we don't really need to flip in
this situation but if you would like me
to show you how to flip leave a comment
below
if you see someone else has already left
a comment saying flip Li you leave a
comment as well and also thumbs is
comment up and then I'll see what the
responses to that anyway for now we
don't need to so we've got all that
we've got these like four sprites now
now what we'll do is actually apply them
so you can see here in the play Clause
first of all we've got a bit of a
problem here because um yeah because of
that now because we renamed it um okay
let's figure out how we're going to do
this so there's a way that I like to do
it okay and I actually like to make a
private sprite variable for myself and
this sprite variable is actually going
to be the sprite variable that gets
applied to the player so right now for
example right the sprite variable is
equal to sprite dot player forward okay
let's just check that check that out so
yeah there we go that works perfectly
right that's what the sprite variable is
equal to that now if we go into the mob
class which of course is the superclass
of play if we go friction control click
on that it's not working there we go I
don't know I don't know what that was
all about
but um if we go into the mob class we
can see that we've got is protected
integer variable that some called
direction right it's equal to zero right
now and we've got four directions
luckily we don't have one direction get
it ha ha anyway we've got four
directions and that's basically zero is
up two is down three is left and one is
right
so using that because we know which way
we're currently heading we can change
the spot accordingly so all we have to
do in player is say that you know if the
direction is equal to the appropriate
direction for that particular sprite so
if this so if we're traveling upwards
which is play forward so in other words
each direction is equal to what 0 then
less display that's right otherwise you
know let's go through all the lists so
that's all you'd really need to do if
Direction is equal to other 2 1 2 3
right and 1 is right so we will just
display player right 2 is down so let's
slow play it back and 3 is um live along
which to left and that's it right that
is it one thing we need to make sure is
the initial direction because if we
don't play if we don't press a single
arrow key or any other control that
we've bound to actually move it's not
gonna know so in other words I usually
would set on negative 1 which means that
basically don't record any input until
something's done that wouldn't work in
this case because well you know it just
wouldn't know what's right to display
and it wouldn't display sprite at all so
in fact in this case it it'll crash with
a non pointer exception yeah so just
just in case I like to be safe with my
code I actually really like going
through code and changing it so that um
you know just in case something weird
happens it doesn't crash the program so
which is why in player like when we're
actually making the player or even up
here I'd probably set the sprite I'd
probably do it here though um I would
spread just in case set the sprite to
play it off forward alright in this case
we're taking care of it because this
will actually be 0 not added 1 but you
know just in case we decide to for
whatever reason set it to negative 1 and
then start the game I don't know why but
you know you got to just make sure you
got everything covered
gasps I just want to set a sprite to
something so that sprite doesn't equal
null because if for some reason it tries
to input this sprite object into render
player and it goes through render play
and it gets up to the power of the part
where it needs to have sprite off pixels
it's going to crash with a null pointer
exception because the sprite object is
equal to null therefore there's no
pixels variable all right
that's something you just need what you
see to watch out for so let's launch our
game and see if this works and look at
that like a boss we are working so
that's that's pretty cool I'm trying to
act as as like what do you call as
amazed as I can obviously have seen this
a thousand times before so it's not cool
but um just FIFA's active you guys well
this is the coolest thing I've ever seen
dude
this play is totally awesome this
totally worked awesome so yeah anyway
guys I hope you enjoyed this episode of
game for rang don't forget to tell me if
you want me to do the sprite flipping
thing otherwise we'll go on to actual
actually animating the player the second
I guess on the second way or the second
step of animating the player so
obviously actually making his legs move
and his yeah his legs move
so yeah anyway I hope you enjoy the
steps of game programming and leave a
like if you did and I'll see you later
guys bye
you